لم يكن الحاج احمد يتوقع ان الامطار ستملا
ارضه بلا ان لا نفعنا
سيول غزيره جرفت النفط الخام المتسربه من
حقول النفطيه في قضاء العلم شرقيه صلاح
الدين الى اراضي الحنطه القريبه منها
فغمرتها
هذا المستوى السيول النفط مع سيول الامطار
الذي دمرت المزروعات بحدود اكثر من 5000
دونم زراعي في مناطق هير الحجر ابو جاون
نتيجه سيول النفط الخام التي لم تعالجها
شركه نفط الشمال
هذه الظاهره حسب السكان سبب التلوثا بيئيا
نتيجه الغازات المنبعثه من النفط
وقد اصيب بعضهم بحالات اختناق في بدايه
الازمه
يعود تاريخ المشكله الى عام 2014 عندما
سيطرت تنظيم الدوله على هذه المناطق بحسب
المسؤولين المحليين الذين يعملون على
توفير الحلول لكن السؤال الان ما هي طبيعه
هذه الحلول وما مصير هذه الارض
احدث عناصر تنظيم الدوله فتحات في انابيب
النفط حينها وبداوا بخزنه داخل التربه قبل
نقله الى اماكن اخرى وفق الروايه الرسميه
اما الحلول فلا تحتاج الى وقت طويل حسب
السلطات لو كانت الانابيب صحيحه ومحكمه
لما تدفق النفط مع السيول اما بالنسبه
لهذه المشكله التي حلت في الاراضي
الزراعيه في قضاء العلم معالجه التربه هي
سحب ماده النفط من التربه يعني عمليه
تنظيف التربه من النفط واعادتها الى وضعها
السابق هي المره الثانيه التي تشهد فيها
صلاح الدين ظاهره مثل هذه وفي العام
الماضي حدث ما هو مشابه لها في كركوك ايضا
مشاكل تتكرر في ظل تحذيرات من تلوث بيئي
قد يصعب السيطره عليه مستقبلا سامر يوسف
الجزيره صلاح الدين